this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you
already know the cash app is the number
one finance app on the app store
well you might not know is that you can
also put cash app in your wallet with
the cash card I had a guy come up to me
the other day in San Francisco and he
showed me the card he was like hey look
at this and he showed me the card that
he made and it had no COO to sign on it
that he designed and it was very cool
it's got boosts it's got great safety
features no credit check needed to get
one so why don't you get one especially
if you're a baby
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play mark guys guess
what cyber [ __ ] Monday its cyber
monday you know what that means every
you know what that means
five million emails when you wake up you
thought you got emails on Black Friday
you get emails you're gonna double it
you're gonna keep doubling it they're
emails you're gonna get emails on on
Friday but you go double it you're gonna
get double the amount of emails all moms
at the Cyber Monday say yeah we got
deals for the babies man you go to Chris
D'Elia calm and you can get this [ __ ]
a hot [ __ ] right here I'm wearing the
daliyah's Grand Slam tea you could go
get that hot [ __ ] you can go get a few
of them do you know why cuz it wouldn't
make a [ __ ] dent if you're a I mean
maybe it does make dents but my butt
dude go ahead and [ __ ] backup that
Brinks truck artwork here that somebody
made Marlon Prue's right there we got it
on the on the video podcast we're gonna
hang up some artwork every now and then
that's what we're gonna do I used to
have the CUDA there but now it's got my
face on the Brinks truck and he says YUM
we're live on my app right now for the
first for the most truest babies you got
to app you can see what's going on there
but yeah man go to Chris D'Elia calm and
get yours and [ __ ]
cyber monday it up this is for free
shipping and there's also a [ __ ] gift
if you spend enough money or some [ __ ]
man people love deals man people love
deals you could be like you want some
fries nah well they're 10% off cool give
me him
you want some fries do you do you want a
bucket a [ __ ] NAMM good on my buckets of
[ __ ] oh it's 10% off all right
where do I put my credit card by the way
the [ __ ] thing isn't up the thing one
fire he didn't set it up what's it
called how do I open it where do singing
he goes like this do oh here it is
got it by the way you want a bucket of
[ __ ] 10% off hey cyber monday y'all good
on your buckets of [ __ ] or did you need
some buckets of [ __ ] dude the amount of
[ __ ] people buy because of a deal is
unreal
hey dude do you want a steak nah just
ate just ate four steaks three minutes
ago
oh yeah it's ten percent off well then
let me get three [ __ ] steaks do you
want a steak now just a dude do you need
a giraffe now why would I need a giraffe
I live in a [ __ ] one-bedroom well its
Cyber Monday where do I put well then in
that case where do I put my credit card
I'll have the giraffe pop his head out
my bedroom window
so anyway dude we're live on the app go
to suck go to Chris D'Elia calm today
only if you're listening to the video
podcast you're not gonna do it the
several mondays over but still go
because daddy's wearing the [ __ ]
daliyah's grand slam shirt do - I did
the show at The Wiltern today did two
shows at The Wiltern
today and today on Friday
now our la plays amazing yeah isn't my
form yeah do family and friends always
want to come yeah do I have to give them
free tickets yes
does it come out of my pocket yeah it
doesn't make a dent no but it's annoying
it's what ya do they want to come back
say yes do you bring them all backstage
no do some people feel slighted
yes is it ok it's fine though those
friends probably but did you still want
to hang out because I want to be in the
in credit yes anyway so I did the shows
at The Wiltern which were really really
fun and really great I love playing the
big shows in LA cuz I'm usually at the
Comedy Store
sometimes at the Laugh Factory in the
improv but it's so fun to do the big la
plays because people still come out even
though they can see me every every week
at the Comedy Store and [ __ ] and it's
just so cool man and we did those play
we did that we did that and then I
started talking about this for some
reason and I forget and that's just how
it's gonna be dude because I need to
start taking some ginkgo biloba or what
are the [ __ ] it's called ginkgo biloba
in color low below lobha geek over lobos
ginkgo biloba
that's what it's called right ginkgo
biloba hey change its name call it ball
soup what's ginkgo biloba
anyways that that [ __ ] with the balls in
it oh that's boba hey if something's
called kinko biloba then don't call
something else boba dude I'll tell you
what man here's the thing that's for
real that I realized about an hour ago
if your name is Scott Sean or Steve
guess what
to me you're just one of those guys I
have no idea what your name is
hey tell me your name Steve okay that's
like saying your name's [ __ ] ginkgo
biloba I won't remember it dude that's
your name Steve or Sean or Scott dude
introduce yourself to me hi what's going
on my name is Chris oh hi I'm steve-o
cool hey you got me that's what I do
when I ain't when I when I meet a guy
named Sean hey Chris I'm Sean oh really
Sean you got me from now on
from now on you got me Steve Sean Scott
first of all the three widest name
of all time the only was named whiter
than that is Adolf or now Donald do
Donald used to be like a black guy named
I feel like when I was in New Jersey
there were so many black guys named
Donald and they call him Donnie and [ __ ]
they're just like yo what's up I'm
Donald oh cool I wanted to be friends
with some Donald's when I was a kid but
now I read a tweet today I think about
that guy Julius
Sharpe is it and he was like there's
gonna be as many in 50 years there's
gonna be many people named Donald as
there are Adolf
that's a funny tweet yeah so what was I
saying though about the Steve Shawn
Scott I have no idea dude
how are there three names that are like
the same like that I'm a white guy I get
confused imagine being a [ __ ]
Japanese guy in in meeting a guy named
Shawn and then meeting a guy named Steve
and then meeting a guy named Scott you
go like this you go to me hello I am you
know whatever something saun kwahm Steve
you go to me hello my name is a Shintaro
what is your name
oh it's Scott you got the Shintaro you
got Shintaro you got this [ __ ] I'm down
for a silly goose time and that's it
you're [ __ ] want to talk
politics saya the [ __ ] Lara do me a
favor catch you later
I'm down for a silly goose time and
that's it dude it was Black Friday
hopefully you didn't get trampled on
hopefully you didn't die people die
every year on four dude that's actually
real sad the day after you give thanks
for everything that you're appreciated
that you appreciate in your life
you [ __ ] trample on someone's face
for a Hitachi hey well I just want to
thank every I want to thank I'm I want
you to know
hey it's 12 p.m. Thursday night I want
you to know thank you so much for
everything my family my my my food my
job I have everything I ever needed and
wanted really the important things thank
God and thank thank my family I have a
running car my house my apartment I have
a place to live I have a roof over my
head and it's 12 feet Oh what happened
it turned 12:01 cool lemme trample on
your face for a Dyson Oh a minute went
by oh well then real quick
lemme bend your [ __ ] fingers back so I
can grab that home in Decker Black and
Decker whatever the [ __ ] it's called so
I can grab that Black & Decker
lemme bend your [ __ ] wedding finger
back anyway yeah so Steve Scott I don't
know yeah there's always somebody dying
on [ __ ] Black Friday nobody dies on
Cyber Monday though cuz they're just
alright
that'd be great if Cyber Monday got so
crazy that someone died that they're
just like hmm trying so hard that their
[ __ ] fingers just catch fire on the
keyboard and they go off and they're
just like cyber monday is now a danger
cyber monday frenzy look at these people
grab and [ __ ] Black Friday frenzy
they're just grabbing leopard print [ __ ]
they don't even need it man we build
this [ __ ] thing where people can't
make we build this society where it's so
hard for people to make money and then
people make deals and then we wonder why
they do it hmm
well we're bad people everyone we're bad
people catch you later
so anyway I feel like I feel like that's
real sad and it shouldn't be and it
should be [ __ ] rectified but what the
[ __ ] do I know I know nothing about that
I was watching that I was watching that
Clinton thing last night
the on A&E the about how Clinton was
just really really loved talking about
policy and really loved and really
wanted to help the world but also
couldn't stop raw dog and random women
yeah let's talk about the economy oh
wait hold on one second hi how are you
please turn around yeah I sure would
like to feed all the homeless in America
wait hold on one second excuse me ma'am
why are your knees on not on the floor
dude the guy they got the guys at dog
Theoden I don't know you know like if
the internet was around when Clinton
well forget it he would have been then I
don't know what he way he but what I'm
watching I'm watching the [ __ ] and it
was like this woman said that he was uh
that he propositioned her or something
on the on the job I don't really
remember already I don't remember I saw
it yesterday by the way needs to take
some [ __ ] ginkgo biloba but uh yeah
it's called the Clinton affair on Annie
and I was watching it and like that's
literally every day now for the
president it's so crazy to see how times
have changed God Bill Clinton was he's
one of those guys that was the [ __ ] and
knew he was this [ __ ] too
like he would just be like then would
they call it the Clinton the full bill
the full Bill Clinton that's what they
call it
like if you paid attention to you and
immediately your [ __ ] got wet even if
you didn't have a [ __ ] if you're a guy
your ball got wet gross it's gross
so anyway I'm watching that and Monica
Lewinski describing like how she had a
crush on him after she met him was just
like she was
dude it's that Power Man some women love
that power [ __ ] that's just how it is
though you know but there's always a guy
more powerful so hopefully your woman
doesn't like the power ship because if
she does you can lose your girl you can
lose your girl when it comes to the
president bro
yes hey dude you think Donald Trump
couldn't steal my girl in a [ __ ] hot
second are you kidding me forget it
that's like big tits for a guy me
walking down the street with my chick
and Donnell and Donny Trump comes by
forget it even Donald Trump's son Doug
Lee won that looks like he's in the
Hills Have Eyes even when he comes by
hey what's up my girl's gone um yeah
Donald Trump could steal my girl no
doubt who's that Eric Trump Jesus Christ
Eric Trump hey Eric Trump why don't you
spread the features out in your face his
eyes and nose I'm Oliver just trying to
have a party together so yeah anyway
what the [ __ ] was I talking about Bill
Clinton Wow dude the notes I have here I
have no idea what any of them mean it's
unbelievable Jesus Christ this is one I
have this is a note I have what could it
mean thinking about life what am i
[ __ ] 15 how much do you think about
life when you're 15 by the way you're
just like you're just like oh oh I
remember what it was oh I remember what
this note was this is hilarious so I was
talking about I was talking to my
Italian friend Ian Frank Authority the
most Italian name of all time John
Franco
torti by the way spelled GI a and not
John do it if you spell John GI a and
year so Italian you might as well be
[ __ ] cream and pizza in your goddamn
mouth so and looking at a painting so so
or painting a painting actually so he
was talking to me he was like the first
place that I ever was in America was
North Carolina and this is so [ __ ]
funny to me I don't know if you got ya
know you know what the babies are like
this [ __ ] so he was doing um he was he
was he he was there he didn't know where
he was I don't even know why he was
there but he was telling me he was
staying in North Carolina maybe with
some friends I don't know but some like
little small town and he went to the
park and he was hanging out on a bench
at a park like a [ __ ] pedophile just
chilling like being so Italian not
knowing not even thinking it's weird
Italians will come to America and do
[ __ ] that is weird kind of but you don't
even like necessarily know it's weird
because you're Italian and it's okay in
Italy like hanging out at a park like it
times you could just go to a park and
chill probably as an Italian and just
roll up your [ __ ] white t-shirt
sleeves and just like be like oh it's a
beautiful day isn't it and have a
cigarette and I throw a ball around and
like when a woman goes by you just go oh
hello you do that then we go look at
that beautiful woman huh how about that
I would love to put my fingers in your
[ __ ] when you walk by just let me hide
my fingers for two seconds
it's a siesta what does it matter it's
midday we don't work from 1:00 till 4:00
let me stick my fingers in your [ __ ]
under your sundress during the siesta
then you go back to sunglass hut so he
was in the small town in North Carolina
chillin on a park bench
and he almost got arrested for it that's
how [ __ ]
American these cops were and that's how
Italian he was the cops drove by and
said hey man what are you doing and it
was his first day in America and he said
well what do you mean that cuz he could
barely speak English English and they
were like what are you doing hanging
around at the park bench and he was like
and he literally said I am a just
thinking about life first of all that's
so Italian to say I'm a just thinking
about life on a park bench it's not even
a new school you I get that snot even
[ __ ] it that's like a tie that's like
a black and white Italian movie that's
like a movie that Fellini made or some
tall lanky string being Italian is just
sitting on a bench alone and a cop drew
the policia come by and they're just
like what do you do it or politte see or
whatever the [ __ ] they call it politican
otso and they say what are you doing and
he says thinking about life and the cop
said and the cops like were like what do
you mean and they gave him a hard time
and they almost [ __ ] arrested him and
he meant and the cop and and the car and
the cops he ended up saying to the cops
can I not beef can I not think about
life on the park bench
I was like and they were probably like
you talking back to us you [ __ ]
Italian that's you know that they were
thinking about does these fat North
Carolina and cops Norton fat North
Carolinian cops dude thinking about life
imagine if you were just some guy and
them in them and the cops came by and
they're like what are you doing in
you're like thinking about life as if
you were a black guy and a white cops
came up to you dude that's the [ __ ]
death sentence meant with the way the
cops treat black people now it's at hey
will you put that fan towards me will
you yeah I already turned it on
yeah swivel it cool great thanks you
know yeah I'm just gonna sort of like
eating the [ __ ] this petition you won
fire so yeah
oh man I mean laughs when he told me
that I hadn't seen him in a long time
and then he came to my will turn show
the long also Houghton is this he came
to The Wiltern show and sat in the front
row and [ __ ] I didn't know he wore
white pants the guy's [ __ ] six six
wore white pants in the front row
couldn't couldn't take my eyes off it
always clocked his white pants it's so
it's oh dude how was I gonna sit there
white pants and spill spaghetti sauce on
it
dude thinking about life that's right
that's what he said ah man so good I
don't know man
and so then I did the San Francisco Show
Saturday which was awesome we did one of
those there at the Masonic theater
there's not a bad seat in the house at
the Masonic theater man it's all they do
that that theater is good they they do
it so it's like it's kind of rounded a
little bit I mean it doesn't go it's not
in the round but it's it's kind of
rounded it there's really not a bad seat
in the house man and there was a great
show and my opener did way too long and
I [ __ ] got mad at him and then for
the first ten minutes I was angry yet
during my set and then I calmed down
because I was like gotta [ __ ] calm
down for the audience gotta make sure
they're good gotta make sure get it some
of these people have been waiting to see
me you know yeah it's not a badge that's
a bad seat in the house they're San
Francisco man I always forget how like
gay San Francisco is no I shouldn't say
how gay it is how out everyone is there
because there are some secret gay people
all over but in San Francisco it's
awesome how they're just like yeah be
gay [ __ ] it I mean everybody was out I
felt like it was just [ __ ] um come on
up I want that well to know I'm comin
out Brown
I mean we got there and everyone was in
wherever we ate was like can I take your
order I've walked in the [ __ ] of what
you walk I mean dude it was cool i I
just you know it will be great the day
there's like super flamboyantly gay cops
that's what that will be this [ __ ] when
there's cops it's never just gonna be
over for the first to do it or you or
somewhere in Utah you know and they just
pull you over they're like do you know
why I pulled you over and you're like oh
was i speeding a little bit and he would
just be like no you looked hot no I just
was I just wanted to talk what's up and
you're like oh [ __ ] gay cops are out now
oh [ __ ] gay cops or some [ __ ] it's like
the gayest profession is like a flight
attendant you know if you're a guy for
some reason being 30,000 feet in the air
makes you want to [ __ ] guys but like one
cops or like military guy or like a gay
sergeant in the military just like a tan
hot we got to go out there and fight the
Iraqis we got to go out there and beat
up Isis attend Hut got the guns go go
and just out that be this [ __ ] out
military guys just like this with their
guns with like a really nice [ __ ]
like it's still camouflage but it's like
a dove it's got like a dope collar and
like a cool like [ __ ] like
fashionable hat like one of those ones
that Pharrell wears but it's camouflage
like [ __ ] the enemies are encroaching
and they'll be like well aren't any of
them good-looking it doesn't matter that
they don't get don't get lost in their
eyes don't get lost in her eyes through
the enemy get um pow and as they shoot
they go also go pow pow
ah shorts on but they're gonna see your
shins [ __ ] it fashion is pain Wow I
can't wait for that day you think I'm
[ __ ] around and joking I'm cuz that's
the thing man this whole thing with like
just like being how it's not manly to be
gay [ __ ] that it is manly to be gay you
can be gay and also manly and cops
should know that and the military should
know that [ __ ] that dude that's how
that's the world I want to live in just
gay ass [ __ ] manly dudes being out
live in their life happy as [ __ ] [ __ ]
guys I loving it gay ass bodybuilders
want it gay ass firemen gay cops
military killing it dude I want to be
protected by them screaming pow pow
while they pulled it while they click
the trigger screaming pear pear will
trigger all right dude gonna do some
[ __ ] ads me undies hey guys this is
the the year that you can finally tackle
your holiday shopping early do it now
guess what you can get everything you
need for you and your loved ones at me
undies it's a great gift their underwear
nobody thinks about getting it for
themselves you can just get the cool me
undies they use coveted micro modal
fabric which is three times softer than
cotton if you never felt this fabric get
ready to experience pure bliss and
underwear form you can also get a style
that is perfectly suited for you men and
women can choose from four different
cuts they're all available with classic
colors and adventurous prints I'm
wearing my right now and wearing my
polkadot ones you know but you can get
the ones for Christmas go now and get
them and then you can give them to them
on Christmas you can get the undies are
launching their holiday prints in lounge
pants too and onesies as well both are
made from the same micromotor fabric as
their undies how can you not get you and
your loved ones a matching holiday
themed onesie this year come on
me on DS has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
when you purchase my enemy on DS you get
15% off and free shipping no-brainer 50%
off a pair of the most comfortable on
these you'll ever put on
so they got onesies go get onesies to
get your 50% off your first pair free
shipping and a 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies dot-com size
Congrats that's me Andy's calm /
Congrats stitch fix is an online
personal styling service that finds and
delivers clothes shoes and accessories
to fit your body budget and lifestyle
just go to stitch fix calm / Congrats
and tell them your sizes what styles you
like and how much you want to spend on
each item you'll be paired with your
very own personal stylist who will hand
pick 5 items to send right to your door
then you could try them on pay for only
what you love and return the rest
shipping exchanges and returns are
always free there's no subscription
required and that's a good thing you can
sign up to receive scheduled shipments
or get your fix whenever you want stitch
fixes styling fee is only $20 which is
applied toward anything you keep from
your shipment so you don't have to pay
on top of that after that get started
now at stitch fix calm / congrats and
you'll earn an extra 25% off when you
keep all five items in your box that
stitch fixed calm / Congrats to get
started today stitch fix calm / Congrats
didn't do it right there we go as usual
your stomach and the post mates you guys
do post mates it's some favorite app for
getting food you as usual your stomach
and the rest of your life rat war you
need to eat but you can't stop doing
what you're going to deal with it a you
can stop doing what you're doing to deal
with it and the only fast things that
deliver are not what you want well post
makes foot post mates fixed that the app
that adds a delivery option to your
favorite restaurants I use it literally
every day
YUM be like me get post mates imagine
anything you want to eat delivered you
don't have to drive park or even talk on
the phone to order just
download the app and order 24 hours a
day 365 days a year
post mates will bring what you want when
you want it within the hour you can even
see where your food is and track your
driver which I do all the time because I
micromanage everything it's awesome
you forget eggs and milk no problem
craving a tasty burger go get it well
you don't have to go anywhere to get it
you just hit buttons and it comes to you
wine or a summer beer order up for a
limited time post mates is giving you
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app today and
use code Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
save the hassle get the food you love
fast at post mates with code Congrats
okay you guys what's up you know that's
the thing too about obviously like I was
looking at this well actually that
what's that basketball net players named
Dwight Howard how he was apparently
supposedly allegedly having sex with
transgendered I don't oh it was a guy
she had sex with someone who identified
was a guy but also dressed as a woman I
don't really know the whole main [ __ ] or
the whole technical [ __ ] about it but
anyway he she I don't I don't know if he
goes by he or she but he they they
exposed him and now everyone's like [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] ignorant people are like
Bill Gross he's gay which is stupid you
know like that's why I was talking about
before the break I was like oh yeah well
I like basketball players gay basketball
players would be the [ __ ] you know
they're there anyway but they can't come
out of the closet which sucks because of
the culture and it was amazing I just
went on online and I looked at people
like I looked at people
[Music]
like bashing him for it you know it was
just like sad like sports culture just
they as of now they're just they have no
room for out players which is so stupid
and I tweeted that this guy tweeted this
thing pull it up you know what I'm
talking about
oh hell can't oh hell naw can't believe
I shook Dwight Howard home alas hands
now with a crying emoji and then the
picture of him and Dwight Howard and
then I wrote this guy asked for a
picture this guy asks for a picture
Dwight Howard was nice enough to take it
with him then this [ __ ] finds out
Dwight Howard is gay supposedly I don't
know whatever and uses the picture to
slur him because of that this is the
worst kind of [ __ ] so I went on this
guy's timeline and I looked at his
timeline and just to you know see what
kind of guy he was and he was saying
[ __ ] like against gays and that's yeah
so he writes yeah go down there look at
this guy what what is it this guy's
weird arguments dude famous people and
people with money are not always happy
at Chris D'Elia has been mentioning me
since yesterday that's sad
I mean he keeps writing back to me ya
know I just wrote about how he's the
guy's an [ __ ] and the guy's like oh
you're a comedian you you're a hypocrite
because you you don't say sorry for your
jokes and I'm like yeah but it's not a
joke
the guy's like he said oh yeah don't
mention Allah's name with with LGBTQ or
whatever there's LGBT what is it they
change they keep changing it and I'm
such an idiot but um he was like yeah
Allah don't use all his name with
something like that talking about some
guy who is for LGBTQ I go down and then
he says LG LBGT and religion don't go
together and every LG b LG LBGT member
knows this read about the story of
Prophet LUT Andry study a religion to me
your loss but to each his own which is
like he's saying like you like don't be
gay and so he's going on and on about
how it's not right and then he's like
calling me a hypocrite cuz I'm making a
joke about it or no cuz I make jokes and
I don't apologize for them I'm like [ __ ]
and then under this guy's [ __ ] he goes
like I scrolled down on his page and it
was like saying [ __ ] like listen before
you judge and understand before NSS like
- well who are these people
dude who are these people it drives me
nuts that some but first of all first of
all it's annoying when somebody tries to
say you can and can't do this we all
know that nobody likes that [ __ ] okay
so to say like you can't [ __ ] a guy
because you're a guy is absolutely
[ __ ] asinine and then to take the
picture to ask a guy for a picture
because you're a fan and then have the
guy take it nice enough didn't have to
and then be like oh look at this [ __ ]
guy who doesn't do what I want him to do
and post a picture and shame him for it
is just you're the lowest kind of person
Europe you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
you're you're a piece of [ __ ] you got
what you wanted and then you're like oh
he's not what I wanted [ __ ] it I'm gonna
put him on blast Europe you know what
you are you're a [ __ ] a hooker that's
what you are you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
you're not a real man your attitude
changed nothing changed but you if
Dwight Howard was gay he's gay then he's
gay then too your attitude changed so
now you're gonna put him on blast for it
when he was nice enough to take a
picture you're the worst kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
religion sucks dude like they [ __ ] put
all these rules on who you can't put
your dick inside of it [ __ ] sucks
like straight up yeah okay you have a
good family unit because of religion but
let's get it to [ __ ] together
religion you [ __ ] suck if you think
you like I don't god it's so hard to
talk about because it drives me nuts
like these religions was like yeah do
whatever you want but also don't do that
like how how do you not see that you're
a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] religion if
that's what you're doing I know so many
religions are like that no I don't
believe in gay oh it's a choice aw this
and that why does it even [ __ ] matter
that much truthfully it doesn't it
truthfully doesn't you don't want to see
it I don't want to see a guy [ __ ] a
girl out at a [ __ ] Starbucks I don't
want to see any of that [ __ ] it doesn't
nothing to do with being gay I don't
give a [ __ ] it just sucks dude if you're
the kind of person that thinks I'm
religious oh yeah oh yeah but it's good
for the families but there's no all
right well so what I don't give a [ __ ]
be good for the world also let people do
what the [ __ ] they want as long as
they're not hurting anybody I just it
drives me nuts man it'd be so cool if a
basketball player came out of the closet
was like I'm gay and I'm gonna still do
slam dunks but you the the it makes it I
mean dude he'd be [ __ ] legit beat up
his like life would be in danger and
that's a huge problem
I wish the Pope would just come out and
be like you know
hey Catholics be gay if you want I don't
know whatever
hey Catholics be gay and then get these
out of the way trip actions there's a
reason half of business travelers do not
use their company's chosen travel
management platform booking business
travel is still ridiculously outdated
time can time-consuming and costly if
you're frustrated with your company's
travel management program or lack
thereof you need to look into trip
actions they take the pain out of
corporate travel with a complete
solution that helps businesses save and
keeps employees happy it's easy to book
a company's business travel from the app
or desktop with 24/7 proactive support
around the globe and incentives for
employees to save on travel expenses
companies large and small see over 90
percent adoption and save up to 34
percent on travel spend when they use
trip actions companies from lyft to Sara
Lee's frozen bakery trust trip actions
with their business travel go to trip
actions dot-com / Congrats complete a 30
minute demo with a trip actions account
executive and you'll get $100 Amazon
gift card but it's this month only trip
actions dot-com / Congrats with a free
demo and $100 Amazon gift card trip
actions dot-com / Congrats I mean tipsy
tipsy elves these are cool man everyone
needs an ugly Christmas sweater this
time of year I got mine from tipsy elves
it's a onesie and it's awesome deck the
halls with one of tipsy elves is
outrageous Christmas sweater designs
they're one-of-a-kind
seriously high-quality and crazy
comfortable to a man you could lounge
around in them it's awesome
after you pick one pick up one or five
of your favorite ugly sweaters check out
some of their other crazy holiday attire
for men you got stylish Christmas suits
for the classiest of holiday gentlemen
interactive sweaters like you got beer
pong cornhole drinking game darts so
Uncle Bob can relive his college glory
days at family dinner be good
your uncle and hilarious team tees and
awesome cozy onesies which I got for
women holiday addresses so you can get
down with your bad elf you guys get that
eye catching legging so you can strike a
festival a festive yoga pose or lounge
around with a cup of spiked eggnog and
teas and comfy onesies you won't find
more hilariously awesome designs
anywhere else so be sure to order from
tipsy elves elves in time for your ugly
Christmas sweater party and right now my
listeners get 20% off tipsy elves calm
when you use my code Congrats at
checkout that's 20% off anything you
order on the site go to tipsy elves comm
and enter my code Congrats at checkout
to get your 20% site-wide discount
square cash you already know the cash
app is the number one finance app on the
App Store what you might not know is
that you can also put cash app in your
wallet with the cash card it's the only
debit card that offers instant rewards
and comes packed with premium features
not even a credit card can offer like
boosts save up to 10% instantly at Whole
Foods Wendy's or Chipotle and more of
your favorite spots or even $1 off
coffee every time you swipe your cash
card at coffee shops across the country
the cash card puts you in control of
your money with extra in-app safety
features they'll let you pause your card
with the touch unlike a credit card
there are no fees ever and the credit
card check isn't required to get one
download the cash app now and get your
cash card for free and of course when
you download the cash app and enter the
referral code congrats you'll receive $5
and the cash app will send $5 - times up
Legal Defense Fund it's a true win-win
so visit the App Store or Google Play
market now you know what I mean because
cash app is the best I love cash app I
use it every single day I pay all my
friends of my homies
we're dinner with it and we'll love them
we love the cash app family also your
family if you shop you guys yeah so a
little bit serious before that last
break didn't I about being gay and
coming out of the closet but that's
what's up I saw Evan Hanson speaking of
gay they the musicals that I just saw
that Evan Hanson
dear Evan Hanson and they were they were
killing it that that [ __ ] is awesome
have you seen dear Evan Hanson dude the
lead on that it's not Ben Platt in the
Los Angeles version but it's I don't
know the guys name but boy was he good I
heard Ben Platt was amazing - he must
have been he won the Tony for it I don't
believe but man it was so funny -
because they like I don't know I mean
obviously like musical theater is like
you know there's a lot of talking about
you talk about sports being gay in
sports is not a quote unquote allowed
the culture doesn't allow it in the
exact opposite when it comes to musical
theater and then Levi Ross is what the
guy was he was God it was great he was
great I went on his Instagram and I went
on Ben Platts Instagram because he did
the original role for jira of enhance
and on Broadway and he can sing them
[ __ ] anyway it was so funny to
imagine first of all cried the whole
time cried the whole time why because
I'm a softie uh yeah I didn't even know
what it was about I didn't know was
about and I sat there and watched it and
the anyway the the guy who it was funny
to think about because the whole play
was good the music was good and then
there was a part where like the guy the
main part Evan Hanson was not in what we
didn't have like a father figure in the
in the in the musical and so this other
father figure I don't wanna ruin it but
this other father figure kind of like is
like in the garage with him and he
teaches him how to like have a glove a
break in a baseball glove it's one of
the songs in the [ __ ] in the in the in
the in the
the musical let me Evan Hansen bass ball
glove so and they to break in a glove as
the song is called and it was so funny
to think of sports which the culture
hasn't caught up with being out yet and
the musical which is like the gayest
thing besides [ __ ] a guy if you're a
guy or eating a [ __ ] if your check and
to see those worlds collide and it was
like it was called to break in a glove
and the guy was like you know how to
break in a baseball glove and the kid
was like oh you you just play baseball
with it and he was like yeah what you
want to do is you want to take shaving
cream and you want to rub it in and you
want to then tie it up real tight with a
baseball in it and you got to do it five
to six nights you got to stick with it
if you want to make it work but that's
how everything is you gotta stick with
it and it was like it was so obvious it
was so funny to think about a gay guy
writing that mused that song it was like
so like like they might have well been
like and that's how you do it if you
want to play the baseball sport like it
was just so running around the bases
with guys with tiny muscles around and
the baseball sport like gay guys are
writing about sports singing you gotta
put the ball you gotta put the ball in
the glove and then tie it around real
tight and then you can play the bass
possible or singing to another guy about
baseball the baseball sport running
around bases and shagging fly ball
and there's an on deck circle and the
baseball spoor just googled it a gay guy
just googled it pinch-hitting mmm
smashing baseball's over the [ __ ]
wall for a homer and if it bounces and
then goes over the wall it's still a
homer but it's it's called the ground
roll double in the baseball work is a
guy baseball running around bases you're
out you're out you're out boners hoops
you're out you're out you're out boners
oops didn't mean the last part rounding
third DoublePlay boners oops plays
[Applause]
running shagging fiber chicka Cox off
the baseball smart man facials the babe
there's a coach rooming the baseball's
burn I mean so funny you got to really
stick with it you got to put a ball in
the baseball mitt you got to put shaving
cream on it and you got to wrap it tight
but you got to do it for nights and
nights on end or it doesn't work but
that's what anything's like in this
world in the baseball spa [ __ ] the
baseball spool or coming on guys up
baseball's fall
hard-looking man if you're a men the
baseball's Ford squirt a gun guys the
baseball spawn so Dom dude this podcast
sucks
spud guys [ __ ] sucks but whatever
helps you back up the Brinks you know
what we had [ __ ] ads today because we
need to back up the goddamn Brinks truck
dude we really need to back up this
goddamn Brinks truck and I'll tell you
what dude cuz it's Christmas and we got
to keep making sure that [ __ ] when
when when I take money out my bank
account it doesn't make a [ __ ] dent
do it that's what we do don't talk about
[Music]
[Laughter]
stop and we need to make that on kill we
need to make tonight kill what is wrong
dude
Christmas getting your gifts before
Christmas wow that's amazing huh my
still favorite one is when the guy goes
huh it's so racist I don't give a [ __ ]
so racist huh doesn't black [ __ ] it all
that
what's up what I don't know man anyway
I've in Hanson's great cried the whole
time
that is what it is my babies I don't
know what these [ __ ] notes are I've
been well christmas is coming up do you
guys are you gonna do your Christmas are
you gonna do your Christmas shopping
early I always say I'm gonna do it early
every year and then I don't do it till
the 27th
I like cut pictures out of stuff I'm
like that's what I got you
I'm the worst dude when I have kids I
hope and I have kids I is that a thick P
people say when you get when you get a
kit when you have kids you you like you
become like more responsible but like
also you could probably become less
responsible - I got to get the kids
gifts when I have kids I gotta have kids
I got to get him gifts dude early but
that's the other thing too if I buy
someone a gift early I'm just gonna give
it to him early I gotta find the balance
in there I gotta find the [ __ ]
balance but yeah good holiday
gift-giving is the [ __ ] I mean look
you can do what you want it's freaking
but you know that mean what's this one
here is this a free conch nice what else
happened this week oh I'm going to
Boston I'm excited for the Boston shows
man we got [ __ ] Wilberforce show sold
out and I'm also playing Medford which
there's some tickets left because I
couldn't get Wilber on the night before
one fire all my well my people but
they're still tickets left for Medford
so you can come to the Medford shows I
would love for you to come by the way we
got to Duke we gotta start looking at
craigslist ads more do you have that he
[ __ ] up one fire
I haven't get rid of isn't even here
right now he's sick so we don't want to
get sick for the Boston shows so
remember you know that shirt this is my
[ __ ] New York shirt
that's sure do you see that go to
Craigslist let's look at some craigslist
ads let's look at some craigslist ass
craig lit craigslist ads by the way
apple you got to stop making [ __ ] that
you can lose so easy how about this
[ __ ] thing look at the video podcast
this connector [ __ ] that you put
with the with the headphones and then
you stick it in your phone go [ __ ]
yourself Apple look at this [ __ ]
this is made for losing you know what
else air pods
dude there should be a if you lose your
air pods you should be able to get air
pods for free again make him at least
make him like neon you know look at this
go to go up scroll up oh wait hold on
okay incredibly hot dark haired guy at
Ralph's on Vineland this I am I used to
go to that Ralph's you were the ink this
is it dude you are the incredibly hot
dark-haired athletic guy in Ralph's at
vine at Vineland oh he's doing it
Wally's there you are there incredibly
hot dark-haired athletic guy in Ralph's
at Vineland and Magnolia in NoHo this
morning very discrete guy here
I got boned just looking at you and
would love to take care of you no recipe
no strings hey what's this guy talking
about we'll Jack you off or otherwise up
to you I like how he gave a suggestion
but also was like you know what whatever
I'm kind of like the my style is i jack
guys off but hey look whatever you're
into you want to [ __ ] me while feeding
me chocolate cake I'll do that too
if this was you reply with description
and we can make it we can take it from
there
I am very discreet and clean and then my
favorite part do not contact me with
unsolicited services or offers imagine
being like hey it's contacting me maybe
like I hate but do you want to buy my TV
though I'll Jack your for whatever you
want
why even here's another one look at this
this one's called rotten cheaters you
are a woman who loathed this cheating
men and wants to talk do not contact me
with unsolicited services or offers we
got to hit up these guys and be like hey
dude I have a couch for sale want to buy
it
what what is that man for a woman head
doctor does that mean suckin dick down
of last one this one who says man for
woman head doctor in parentheses Covina
looking for a white girl who loves to
deep throat hmm do not contact me with
unsolicited service or offers god that
makes me want to [ __ ] just say I've
got some best buy coupons I'll sell to
you for half price
too thick to the thick woman at hole
what is this world to the thick woman at
Whole Foods Porter Ranch in parentheses
Porter Ranch oh thanks but that's where
it was cool said in the title this was
that whole food in Porter Ranch on 1120
118 I was in the baking aisle I think
and I kept locking eyes with a nice
thick extra curvaceous woman but I
didn't get the chance to say something
and I'll admit I liked what I had seen
you definitely had some booty on you
very thick or extra thick curvy what you
passed me a few times so not sure if you
wanted to say something also but if you
think this is you message me maybe we
can chat and exchange some pics to see
if it was you do not contact me with
unsolicited service or offers I like how
he said scene you definitely had some
booty on you very thick or extra thick
curvy like if you're the woman that's
look that going to this encounters [ __ ]
on Craigslist you're like I was very
thick not not curvy no it wasn't me
he'll make it work if she's looking you
know man these are the best man checking
out the Bulge
that's what the title is by the way if
there was a movie called man checking
out the Bulge that'd be the only movie I
would get tickets before it came out no
doubt with Liam Neeson if he with Liam
Neeson was in a movie called man
checking out the Bulge
I would pre-order all of the tickets to
my closest theater opening day I'm
checking out your bulge I have got a
special set of skills it's for checking
out bulges if you've got a bulge I will
find you if you've got a bulge in your
jeans I will find you and I will kill
you but before that I'll suck your [ __ ]
I'll jack you off or whatever you want
[Laughter]
hello if you've got a bulge I will find
you and I will kill you
but first I'll jack you off or whatever
you want it's up to you anyway after
that I will kill you man checking out
the Bulge santa clarita you were in the
meat aisle I was wearing tight jeans
with no underwear
you saw the Bulge and looked at me and
smiled you stared I never wear underwear
love to show it off again do not contact
me with unsolicited services or offers
or I will kill you
but first I'll jack you off while I wear
no underwear or whatever you want dude I
like how he made a cute you were in the
meat aisle like wink wink I was wearing
tight jeans with no underwear by the way
you wouldn't be able to know if you were
you saw the Bulge and you looked at me
and smiled if it was Liam Neeson I would
be on a train I was on a train and it
was going nonstop you were I wasn't
wearing underwear something else that
was non-stop was my bulge
it went around the side of my hip and
back towards my ass so you could have
seen my bulge when I was walking away
hooked around you might have seen the
tip of my penis on this in the middle of
my right butt cheek because that's how
far it bends around my bulge anyway jack
me off or whatever you want it's up to
you but I will kill you I will find you
oh look at this
can I taste you again how did this guy
taste the guy already and not get his
info hey let me [ __ ] suck your dick
bye oops I should have got his email
well guess I gotta go to Craigslist we
used to meet up early between 8:00 and
9:00 a.m. and I would service you orally
and you'd return the favor it was
nothing more than mutual oral I'm hoping
I can find someone to continue this with
I like how it's hey if you're not this
guy but reading this I'm down if you
like what you hear please feel free to
respond I'm a married Latino five seven
husky built 275 well I'll say Wow Jesus
Christ five seven 275 husky built mm-hmm
very clean good hygiene tanned
complexion few tattoos do not scon tact
me with unsolicited services or offers
Wow husky build I'll say more like fat
guy huh
how about [ __ ] fat guys were like
yeah I'm husky yeah yeah a ski or did
you roll here did you head hit the
ground at any point
did you roll here I don't know should we
do Twitter questions are there questions
here we have some kind of taste you
again hey can I taste you again oh let
me get your email no well whatever aaja
go let me take you um okay what do you
think about at Chris D'Elia
this is JC Le 94 what do you think about
non-military people using military time
on their phone and making a point to
tell you the time military time well I
had an ex-girlfriend that still does
this she's a friend of mine but she uses
military time for some [ __ ] reason I
don't know why I choose to go on hikes
maybe that's why I don't know but she
won't say it's [ __ ] 1830 that would
drive me nuts if you do that and you
have nothing to do with the military
even if you do adapt to society you know
what I mean nobody's wearing [ __ ]
camo around here unless you know unless
you are but then you're kind of one time
I was at a Busta Rhymes concert concert
and I saw a chick in full camo gerd dant
like at the concert like bought a ticket
and she was in front of me I also can't
believe I was at a Busta Rhymes concert
I was 19 my buddy wanted to go and and
when I was watching it he was like my
buddy was Busta Rhymes was like this is
the best part of any cons I've been to
his like this next dance is called the
take off your clothes and he would do
this song and he was just pretending to
take pretending to take his clothes off
like miming what it would be like if he
took his clothes off that's it
and it will be like the ticket into June
the ticket into June
did you with no delay and so what you
see in yo nothing silly Whitman a milli
would really oh okay
and it was pretending to take his pants
off while saying that ridiculous um the
Damien Montez at nipples and toes 28
change it it's free conch but change it
what was your last game system you had
before life came in I mean what was this
guy a [ __ ] robot what was your last
game system you had before life came in
life came in you mean
and until I grew up do you still play
video games now I don't I have all the
systems for some reason last game system
I have it so I have them all I just
don't play him and that's it really
about that [ __ ] way to go with that
question bud no yeah I don't really play
video games cuz I don't want to start
off born I want to start off mario
already if you make me start off I swear
to God I played a game where the first
opening of the game there's the last
game I played the opening of the game
was you came out of your mom's vagina
and then you had to learn stuff hey no
hey no okay I want to start out with a
mustache already in a video game
I mean Oh up it you got it
learn how to crawl what what I think was
fallout the game fallout Bobbili was
like you gotta play this game and I
bought it and then [ __ ] legitimately
opened my eyes for the first time the
video in the video game that you're a
baby hide no a video game creators where
is the mushroom for me to jump on that's
it
[Music]
Austin Lopez who are some of your
favorite directors David Lynch Stanley
Kubrick favorite of all time
Jean John Cassavetes I like other ones
too
also my dad favorite director
but ya know uh I love Kubrick cuz you
can tell by his movies that he just
[ __ ] loved making them I like David
Lynch cuz he's a [ __ ] lunatic have
you ever been on David Lynch's website I
don't know if it's like this anymore but
like eight years ago I went on and it
has like short films and artwork that he
does which is all incredible and then he
has a part where you can click on the
weather and he does weather reports
he's like sunny day here in Malibu not a
cloud in sight and that's it and he's
sitting outside on his patio a little
bit of rain coming down from the clouds
precipitation is always something we
need sometimes anyway have a good day in
Los Angelenos
so funny David Lynch love his [ __ ] and
John Cassavetes best favorite of all
time because that dude I read books on
him and [ __ ] first of all he he was the
only director to me that I've seen I'm
sure there's other ones there are other
ones I'm not that cultured but like to
me that dude captured exactly how life
was and he made a movie called husbands
with Peter Falk
Ben Gazzara and John Cassavetes in it
isn't it and it's a real hard movie to
find but it's it's that and swingers are
they're my two favorite movies to watch
it's so much captures what it's like
being a guy and more so than any other
movie I've seen it's so funny and so
good and I [ __ ] love it dude I love
the movie husbands it's my favorite
movie these guys just their friend dies
and then during the eulogy or during the
when the priest is giving the eulogy or
whatever it is they're just he's just
being very general about it he's just
like yay everyone loved him he was a
great guy and you know he this and that
and then afterwards the three dudes that
I mentioned
they're driving away from the funeral
they're driving from the funeral they're
like they're like they didn't that was a
[ __ ] eulogy they didn't even [ __ ]
talk about how it really was and these
guys to deal with their grief they just
leave and go to Paris
I think it's Paris or Europe all right
what a London London its London
yeah it's London yes London and they go
and they just go and they like go for
three nights and they like our
philandering with women and [ __ ] and
they're just being such dumb [ __ ]
[ __ ] guys and it's so funny I love
the movie it's so funny dude also I like
Cassavetes movies because you can just
turn them on whenever like in the middle
and just watch them woman under the
influence is amazing dude that what's
the lady's name what's her name again
Jenna Rowland's he was married to her
and she's in that movie and she plays a
[ __ ] like a mentally unstable woman
and she's so it's one of the best
performance I've ever seen also faces is
a great movie
I get so hard to watch faces I mean it's
so boring but I love it I love boring
movies sometimes he was the best man
John Cassavetes I love that guy's [ __ ]
movies killing of a Chinese bookie loved
it that movie got pans too but I loved
it
dude Ben Gazzara is so good in that
movie there's a scene in the movie where
he gets into his limo and the whole
scene is him sitting there and he says
I'm terrific that's the best I mean dude
nobody captured what it's like being a
guy better than John Cassavetes in a
movie it just he he was great [ __ ] he
was a great movement filmmaker he was
influenced by uh I think a lot of French
filmmakers I think I can't remember it's
been a long time since I uh since I read
up on him I remember I read this is how
cute I was do it in high school I read a
book on
Cassavetes and I liked the book so much
I just loved him I loved what he was
about and I liked the book so much I
think it was the book
Cassavetes on Cassavetes it was like an
interview it was like him talking about
himself but it wasn't like any any
interview for him even though it kind of
was but I loved the book so much that I
didn't read the last page because I
didn't want to finish I wanted to
currently be reading the book for the
rest of my life and that is the cutest
[ __ ] I've ever done and I forgot about
that I never read that last page of the
book
because I never wanted to wanted it to
be finished because I always wanted to
be currently reading it hey cute I
challenge you to [ __ ] ever do
something cuter than that
cuz cutest [ __ ] for that dode mMmmm
cutie [ __ ] Wow
maybe one day bright before right before
I right before I die read that last page
what if that last page he was just like
psych I'm just joking
didn't mean any of it and then if you'd
like to make a car um well that's it my
babies add a little bit of extra time
today because we had an extra add in
there and I wanted to make sure that
everybody got their [ __ ] fix you know
what I mean I don't like when people to
say that got to get my fix and then
talking about like a podcast or cheese
say yeah listen if you download my app
do it now you can see this podcast
before anybody sees it a whole day early
or more than a day early you see it live
you see ten minutes the first [ __ ]
ten minutes live and you get to
communicate with other babies on the app
it's [ __ ] cool but go to Kruk go to
download go to whatever app you whatever
you go to get your apps if you got
iTunes itunes or the App Store you go to
the wherever the [ __ ] I forgot some
other Samsung [ __ ] I tuned I what he
called it a App Store and you type in
Crystal you just type in my name
got some dates coming up it's still
Cyber Monday though if you're listening
to this so go get merch I got a show
coming up in Medford Massachusetts
Thursday Medford Massachusetts on
Thursday there are tickets left then I
got four shows at the Wilbur sorry
he snooze you lose they're all sold out
cuz I had to [ __ ] back up the goddamn
drink drink box Brinks truck Bakersfield
California Fresno Louisville
Indianapolis st. Louis Boulder Colorado
Springs Madison Milwaukee [ __ ] that's
sold out Chicago Chicago sold out and I
have to do another Chicago day because
of that I'm gonna add that soon Seattle
Hamilton Ontario Hamilton Ontario in
Windsor Ontario Kalamazoo Anaheim San
Ynez Valley Center California there's a
lot of these Hanover Huntington
Cleveland Columbus Cincinnati Lexington
Albuquerque Santa Fe Phoenix Tucson
Greensboro Charlotte Durham Newport News
for some reason Oakland California and
Las Vegas Newport News Virginia and the
[ __ ] is out of phase download the cash
up for free at the App Store or Google
Play market and two rewards code
Congrats get $5 and give $5 - times up
yeah it's the last day for free domestic
shipping on the store Plus free mystery
shirt while supplies last on orders over
$75 subscribe to the YouTube channel
because we like that
get tickets to my tour subscribe rate
and review the show it really helps
us in the rankings and the rankings are
a good thing for us the more we go up
the more we go up so yeah thanks a lot
and I got a new special coming out on
Netflix soon enough it's a half hour for
you so a member you got Gintoki what is
that well you got this in total all
right my babies thanks for listening
love you guys
[Music]